who's the funniest player on the Suns
who's the funniest on the team maybe
book he just says some little comments
here and there that just hilarious if
you had to play a different professional
sport what would it be I don't think I'm
built for another sport what's the best
and worst part of being 7'2 um
basketball of course the worst part
ducking under doors sometimes closed
you're really into fashion who is the
best fits in the league I'm going to say
myself of course what's one food you
can't live without friends toe it has to
be good though it's rare if you had to
shop at one clothing store for the rest
of your life What would to be maybe like
H Lorenzo or Dober Street what is your
biggest fear but I don't like crazy
animals like snakes and spiders what is
the most adventurous thing you've ever
done probably go to Hawaii have you ever
tried a weird food no I'm not for all
the weird food at all what's the best
concert you've ever been to probably
future if you could give a piece of
advice to your younger self what would
it be I wouldn't say anything to him
what is your favorite reality show I
don't watch TV